the world of disney and harry potter
have more than just magic in common
they both have male leads that we've
been obsessing over for years
have you ever thought about what your
favorite disney princess would look like
in the wizarding world
that's why we're reimagining disney
princes as the heroic
and not so heroic boys of hogwarts and
beyond
it's time for hercules to trade in his
god-like clothing for a good ol
weasley jumper have you ever wished you
could see flynn rider
ride a broom accio transformations
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we love mashups why choose between your
favorite characters if you can just
transform them into one another
problem solved now we can't stop
imagining these disney princes
walking the hallways of hogwarts what
houses would they be sorted into
and who would their princess
counterparts be what do you think
sounds like we could definitely explore
all those questions together in another
video
thanks for watching
[Music]